les frères spéciaux des frères spéciaux
ouais y'a un guest aussi qui a participé
aux frères quelqu'un est là qui a fait
plein de choses avec moi depuis c'est
combien de temps 6 ans et embauche à 6
ans a pas sa maman
regardez-la participer il a participé au
tout dernier frère en tout cas avec moi
de l'histoire des frais variables
on connaît qu'est ce que vous pensez des
transports en commun parisiens
je dirais que c'est un très bon système
même en fait et votre frère elle en
pense quoi
mon frère me vicq en france que n'y a
pas vraiment de c'était la caméra cachée
sabine est bon on embrasse toute la
famille les montmirail on pense fort à
vous
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens à je trouve que
c'est bien des fois c'est bien et votre
aide en pense quoi à votre frère mon
frère il est à madagascar qu'à six
reprises aux 30 seul un bon soir mais
c'est à mon frérot comment tu vois tu
connais
[Musique]
[Rires]
en 2000 je pense que
si vous êtes plus avoir le téléphone
dedans elle ouverte toute la nuit
c'est le truc génial je ne suis pas de
paris mais je trouve scandaleux est
votre fringue luxueuse en pense quoi
j'ai pas le faire j'ai pas de soeur
alors moi il en pense que c'est
scandaleux aussi dans ses missions
j'adore ces visions d'or balader sur
quiconque tombe exactement
alors il balade dans paris ne suis même
pas disparue balade sur la chemise en
reste des petits pois lentilles grand
c'est beau comme tout est un peu à la la
ça nous fait plaisir de vous voir la
peine mais aussi aux familles alors bon
bah écoutez les coûts les loulous ça
nous fait plaisir de m'approcher racon à
paris on appelle les magnifiques
machines
qu'est ce que vous pensez transports en
commun parisiens mais cher monsieur à
partir d'aujourd'hui c'est un grand
bordel ce matin saint lazare le métro ça
va mal en fait mal c'est le bordel c'est
parce que la france est mon second pense
quoi mais écoutez j'ai pas de serre
jusqu'à aujourd'hui j'ai pas de serre
bon appui de pineau elle fait pas mhd
plus aux soirées mot qui convienne
marathon au sauter la plus jeune du
quartier regarde la bande am n'a su
service ave site avait 30 ans de plus
c'est vrai qu'est ce qui se serait passé
si j'avais fait que je prendrais bien
l'aider à bien et bien camille on va y
aller je crois pas écouté on va les
amène à les bâches au gène aura un petit
camion jusqu'à la section encore la
patte aux jouets à verser très fort car
adams et toutes les personnes impliquées
pour l'ate sais que je t'aime très rod
est toujours là pour nous aider à la
merci frérot